bd mais ba doit appeler squeeze hausse
comment allez-vous on écrit juste
d'entrée de jeu j'espère vous avez passé
un très bon noël et qui vous est rien
arrivé de creepy en tout cas on finit
l'année comme elle a commencé avec un
trader les histoires sont assez folle et
y en a une qui est un peu dans le
surnaturel français pas trop et c'est ça
que j'aime bien habituellement moi je
suis pas très fan surnaturel vous le
savez ayant n'a jamais dansé serait
d'horreur parce qu'on se base sur des
témoignages sur de vraies histoires donc
comment prouver qu intrication
naturelles ou non il faut envoyer le
grand j d voilà je vais pas l'appeler à
chaque fois pour lui demander d'aller
vérifier donc généralement je me tiens
des témoignages très rationnel mais là
j'avoue il ya une histoire c'est une
petite d'un gris je me suis dit il faut
que je la raconte elle m'a un peu touché
elle a un peu hérisser les poils on
commence avec la première l'histoire
l'histoire hashtag had ou
quand reverrai-je pays merveilleux
vous êtes stressé oui un peu je skie pas
souvent et j'ai le vertige moi je suis
moniteur je suis grave le boss et
comment vous faites pour pas avoir peur
déjà je regarde les magnifiques
montagnes des alpes en face de moi c'est
vrai que c'est beau on dirait que c'est
pas réel on dirait un jeu vidéo n'est ce
pas oui un peu je pensais plutôt à une
chine impact j'allais plutôt dire une
peinture non parce que gagnent chine
impact se sont inspirés des alpes pour
un événement spécial avec la station
vélo torrent j'ai aucune idée de quoi
vous parlez kenshin à pâte est un jeu
d'action rpg ou un frère une soeur se
retrouvent séparés par une déesse a
connu le joueur va pouvoir incarner l'un
des deux personnages pour partir à la
recherche de l'autre la dernière version
2.3 se passe dans la montagne dragon
spin inspiré des halles cette hyper
dangereux votre ipad au dessus du vide
là pas grave s'il tombe j'en gagnerai
peut-être un nouveau durant l'événement
du 29 décembre attendez il ya des
cadeaux dans votre jeu j'adore les
cadeaux oui pour participer il te suffit
de rejoindre l'événement via le lien
dans la description est au bout du
millionième visiteur illumineront les
alpes ok trop cool j'ai atteint et c'est
pas tout il y aura une cérémonie en
janvier avec un concert je pourrais
chanter je chante super bien non c'est
pas un karaoké vous êtes jaloux car je
chante mieux que vous - au moins je sais
ce qui est moi aussi c'est juste les
bancs volant qui me font peur
on appelle ces des télésièges ok pas la
peine de vous la péter ok maintenant que
vous avez téléchargé gagne chez l'impact
on peut passer vraiment à la première
histoire celle de nathan à l'époque
nathan vit donc dans la demeure
familiale avec ses parents et sa soeur
on est en 2008 et donc son père vient
d'avoir foxtel le foxtel qui est la
télévision câblée en australie en
revanche avec un seul câble ce qui fait
qu'à la télé que dans le salon mais
nathan il veut absolument une télé dans
sa chambre pour résoudre ce problème il
a de la chance on perd c'est un peu un
geek et décide d'acheter un émetteur
récepteur av vous connaissez le principe
on branche un émetteur à la télé qui est
dans le salon et il est chargé d'envoyer
l'image un récepteur qui lui est branché
à la télé de la tente dans sa chambre on
est samedi et n'attend pas son après ma
installer le matériel assez top tout ça
pour ensuite pouvoir mater la télé
tranquille et on a de la chance parce
qu'à l'époque il a pris des photos de
l'installation au place à vous plonge
tout de suite dans le passé à la vue de
cette télé vous avez la nostalgie revue
c'est normal et vous allez voir par la
suite que c'est très cool qu'il ait pris
des photos ce jour-là nathan il galère
installé le truc et débrancher
rebrancher n'y a pas d'image il comprend
pas et soudainement l'image grésy
tout de suite d'intenses djs ça y est
j'ai réussi je vais enfin pouvoir mater
la télé dans ma chambre et immédiatement
il est plus trop content parce qu'il
réalise qu'il ya une image alors qu'il
n'a pas encore allumé l'émetteur reliés
à la télé du salon comment son récepteur
pour recevoir une image si le truc qui
est censée la lui envoyer était éteint à
ce moment-là nathan décide donc de
prendre une photo et voici donc l'image
qui apparaît dans sa télévision
c'est affreux voilà c'est horrible
nathan panique quand vous aurez tous
paniqué je pense à sa place et en plus
il croit que ce qu'il voit à l'écran
c'est son lit à lui bref ça le terrorise
et du coup il rejoint sa soeur à l'état
joncour ont ils redescendent tous les
deux dans sa chambre il regarde l'image
et puis là il réalise que c'est
absolument pas le lille nathan convoi
ils ont tiré une conclusion évidente
c'est que le récepteur qu'il achetait
est en train de capter un signal qui
traînent dans le coin ça veut dire que
ce qu'ils voient dans l'écran c'est pas
très loin de chez eux mais en même temps
ils se disent mais qui ferait une caméra
comme ça qui filme son lycée creepy de
fou quelques heures plus tard les
parents de nathan rentrer à la maison et
immédiatement nathan et sa soeur leur
raconter y dessine tous les cas tu de
regarder ce fameux signal pendant
plusieurs heures voire 6 passe un truc
et pour ted avoir des indices savoir
d'où ça vient qui sait peut-être
prévenir la personne en question bref le
temps passé d'un coup il se passe
quelque chose quelqu'un entre dans la
pièce le père de nathan reconnaît tout
de suite cette personne c'est leur
voisin le père de nathan tout de suite
il a trois hypothèses la première c'est
que l'un des deux a peut-être installé
cette caméra qui a l'air d'être une
caméra espion pour s'assurer que l'autre
ne le trompe pas la deuxième c'est que
peut-être qu'ils aiment se filmer en
train de kent possible la troisième qui
est beaucoup plus fumeuses c'est que
peut-être que le mari est un psychopathe
qui veut se filmer en train de tuer des
gens bon le père m'a temps à regarder
trop documentaire sur les salles killer
mais malgré tout il décide de ne pas en
parler à leurs voisins parce qu'ils se
disent mais attend ses intimes c'est
sûrement un truc privé est toujours n'a
pas intervenir éteignons la télé on fait
comme si on n'avait rien vu on passe à
autre chose mais malgré ça n'attend il
est petite curiosité morbide et pendant
plusieurs jours il va regarder en
journée à des moments random s'il se
passe un truc malheureusement plutôt
heureusement il va rien se passer de
spéciale pendant ces jours là où il
allume la télé et donc il passe à autre
chose le temps passe les semaines
passent nathan repenser un peu à cette
histoire et un jour et décide de
rallumer les récepteurs et là il tombe
sur une dinguerie on est dans une
période où leur voisin faisait
énormément de travaux chez eux par
curiosité nathan rallume son récepteur
et voit un homme un ouvrier rentrer dans
la chambre cet homme ils ont croisé
plusieurs fois dans la rue quand il se
rendait à la maison et c'est en fait un
plombier bon plutôt logique qu'ils
traînent dans les pièces de la maison il
a probablement des trucs à checker
concernant la tuyauterie est tout sauf
que là ce qui fait c'est qu'ils loupent
des tiroir de la commode ya pas de tuyau
dans le tiroir d'une commode nathan face
à ça et se dit tiens bizarre il appelle
immédiatement sa mère pour qu'elle
vienne regarder avec lui ce qui se passe
hélas ce qu'ils voient c'est horrible il
voit cet homme qui
les sous vêtements de leurs voisines et
qui se met à les renifler c'est pas un
passe temps comme un autre bref ils sont
choqués par ce qui vient de se passer et
ce qui suit est pire ils marchent tout
droit vers la caméra et regardent droit
dans l'objectif et puis il replace un
peu la caméra et il se barre
immédiatement on attend et sa mère
comprennent que cette caméra elle n'a
pas été mise là par leurs voisins elle a
été mise là par cet homme qui
apparemment veut pouvoir les voir à leur
insu dans leur intimité dans leur
chambre la mère de nathan ne veut pas
confronter ses voisins parce que c'est
trop crij c'est trop horrible pour elle
et donc elle demande à son mari de
foncer et de les avertir de ce qu'ils
ont vu son mari va donc toquer chez ses
voisins il ouvre la porte et ils leur
expliquent leur dis voilà écoutait je
crois qu'elle caméras chez vous qui
filme en direct votre chambre les
voisins comprennent absolument pas de
quoi il lui parlait donc ils lui disent
bas vas-y vient et allons dans la
chambre et regardons ça ensemble dans la
chambre le père de nathan se dirige donc
vers la position de la caméra en se
basant sur l'angle qui l'a vu sur la
télé chez lui et il comprend qu'elle est
dans le mur il dit donc aux voisins de
lui faire confiance et ils commencent à
percer le mur et dans le mur y trouve de
trucs le premier truc qui trouve sa un
appareil qui est là pour surveiller sa
consommation d'eau parce qu'à l'époque
en australie dans cette région là il y
avait eu d'immenses sécheresse donc le
gouvernement avait émis des restrictions
de consommation d'eau et la deuxième
c'est évidemment une caméra espion relié
à un boîtier émetteur le plombier et est
donc venu faire son taf c'est à dire
installer ce fameux appareil dans le mur
mais il en avait aussi profité pour
ajouter cette caméra la police ouvre
donc une enquête parce que c'est quand
même mes gars grave elana temps et sa
famille ont pu nouvelles du truc pendant
des semaines un jour la mère de nathan
croise par hasard sa voisine et elle lui
explique qu'en fait la police a
découvert que le mec venaient tous les
soirs se garer dans un van juste à côté
de leur maison pour pouvoir capter le
signal qu'ils émettaient la caméra
espion et les regarder tout simplement
pendant des heures dans leur chambre à
leur insu nathan a donc littéralement
sauvé ce couple d'intrusion méga intime
je pense que c'est la hantise d'un peu
tout le monde ici est de filmer à ton
insu comme ça c'est ignoble aujourd'hui
on sait que ça peut arriver on sait que
la technologie le permet mais en 2008 ne
serait jamais douté de sa c'est abusé
bref les frérots plombier
prévenez nous pas si vous voyez un
collègue crépy toute façon je vous
appelle plus je préfère vivre avec des
fuites d'eau c'est clair laissez moi
vous raconter maintenant l'histoire de
paul histoire très étrange dans cette
histoire ya donc paul meilhat aussi
c'est trois meilleurs amis qui
s'appellent respectivement kevin ryan et
tommy alors cette histoire a eu lieu il
ya quelques années déjà mais sachez
qu'ils sont toujours meilleurs potes
aujourd'hui et qu'ils en parlent assez
fréquemment parce que ça les a
absolument terrorise c'est l'été on est
mi juillet et paul et ses trois amis
décident de partir en vacances dans le
cabanon de kevin tout au nord de la
forêt du minnesota alors c'est un lieu
qu'ils connaissent bien ils sont allés
plein fois en famille avec leurs parents
mais cette fois il décide d'y aller seul
parce qu'ils sont assez grands pour le
faire alors contexte sur la position de
cette cabane parce qu'en fait elle n'est
pas dans la forêt elle est sur une très
grande île qui est juste à côté de la
forêt île sur laquelle se trouve pleins
d'autres cabane sauf que la cabane la
plus proche de celle de kevin et à au
moins 800 m pour accéder à la cabane en
voiture il faut donc arriver en voiture
de l'autre côté de la rive prendre un
bateau est ensuite débarqué sur l'île la
cabane thing about classique à deux
chambres côte-à-côte détail qui a son
importance il ya une fenêtre dans chaque
pièce mais il n'y a pas de rideaux aux
fenêtres tu es vraiment plongés au coeur
d'une forêt tu vois les arbres tu vois
la nature tu vois ce qui se passe bref
notre groupe de potes seront donc dans
cette cabane il est bon pour une durée
de 4 5 jours et globalement jusqu'au
troisième jour tout se passe bien le
soir de ce troisième jour ils sont
posées au bord du feu en train de boire
des bières de se raconter des histoires
franchement la vie avec un grand v ils
profitent des étoiles et du calme mais
d'un coup ils entendent un bruit qui
vient du lac rien ne regarde au loin et
il dit les gars c'est quoi ce truc dont
quatre amis regardent dans la direction
que pointe ryan du doigt et il voit ce
qui ressemble d'après les mots de paul à
une tête qui flottent au milieu du lac
mais bon paul et ses amis reste très
pragmatique qui se disent bon on voit
pas de fou le truc est à 100 m c'est
probablement un tueur c'est des oiseaux
vagabond nocturne qui chassent donc très
tard et y en a énormément autour du lac
bref petit coup de pression quand même
pour notre groupe d'amis qui décide
quand même de reprendre la soirée en
mode bon les gars c'est un oiseau
continué de boire des bières
amusons-nous on est stressé pourrir là
on a plus de 12 ans le temps passe et
paul a envie d'aller aux toilettes sauf
que la salle de bains est déjà prise par
l'un de ses amis il se lève il se
rapproche du bord du lac pour faire sa
petite affaire et en levant les yeux il
revoit au loin cette fameuse tête sauf
que cette fois elle est plus à 100 m
elle est à 50 mètres il retourne en
courant voir ses potes et l'ordi les
mecs s'il vous plaît venez avec moi
c'est chelou cette histoire de tête dans
l'eau là sauf qu'il est tard que le feu
est en train de s'éteindre et sont
fatigués ils sont déjà pris une fois un
coup de pression voyons tous la tête et
donc du coût 10 à paul frérot vient
plutôt on rentre dans la cabane on ferme
les portes et on se couche quoi il est
tard tout le monde se couche sauf paul
qui regarde une dernière fois par la
fenêtre voir s'il revoit cette fameuse
tête et il est rassuré parce qu'elle
n'est plus là mais d'un autre côté il
est dingue parce que il sait pas ce que
c'était il en a pas eu le coeur net ça
peut être plein de trucs mais lui il a
vraiment l'impression que c'était une
tête et ça le stress paul ne s'endort
pas tout de suite il un sommeil pas ouf
et pendant qu'ils galèrent à s'endormir
il entend des bruits de pas qui viennent
des marches qui mènent à la cabane sauf
que le bruit dure trois minutes mais que
monter les escaliers sam et 12 secondes
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel après
ce qui lui a semblé être une éternité
paul entend les bruits pas s'accélérer
et partir au loin dans la forêt et à ce
moment ryan sort de sa chambre regarde
tommy épaules et leur dis les gars on se
casse les trois amis de ryan comprennent
pas ce qui se passait du coup du 10 mai
qu explique nous pourquoi tu veux qu'on
se barre est ce qu'ils leur expliquent
ce jour là ils s'en souviendront toute
leur vie il était dans son lit dos à la
fenêtre et il a changé de position pour
être plus confort il s'est donc retrouvé
face à la fenêtre et c'est là qu'il a vu
quelqu'un dans le coin supérieur droit
de la fenêtre quelqu'un qui s'est décalé
immédiatement après cryan les bus nos
amis sortent de la cabane descendre les
escaliers et là il voit des traces de
pas les bruits que paul a entendu plus
tôt était donc réelle y avait bel et
bien quelqu'un qui était autour de la
cabane nos amis sprint jusqu'au bateau
démarre le moteur et rejoindre l'autre
rive sur le trajet paul a les yeux rivés
sur le lac la cabane la forêt les
alentours mais ne voit rien ils
atteignent donc la rive iran voiture est
au bout de seize kilomètres de routes
ryan fait une énorme crise d'angoissé
il appelle donc ses parents qui sont les
plus proches délais où ils se trouvent
et ils viennent les chercher bref cette
villa vous l'aurez compris ils ont vécu
l'enfer et personne n'a dormi l'histoire
s'arrête là à ce jour paul il n'est pas
capable d'expliquer ce qui s'est passé
et il a rien compris paul et ryan ne
sont jamais retournés à la cabane en
revanche tommy et kevin ils sont
retourné plusieurs fois avec leurs
parents pas seuls et ils ont jamais revu
quoi que ce soit d'anormal pas les
pragmatiques il explique qu'il ya plein
de gens qui ont une cabane sur cette île
et que clairement c'était peut-être une
farce puisque cette nuit là ils ont bel
et bien croiser la route de quelque
chose de surnaturel quoi qu'il en soit
il avait bu quelques bières il n'avait
pas pris de drogue ou quoi que ce soit
ce soir là et deux d'entre eux ne s'en
sont jamais remis bref c'est une
incroyable histoire c'est tout ce que je
déteste voilà fuck les cabanes aller
sans transition on passe à la troisième
histoire c'est celle d'une française qui
s'appelle emi qui a 14 ans au moment où
il nous la raconte et d'histoire s'est
passé quand elle en avait 4 son histoire
c'est un mix de ses souvenirs à elle de
ce qui s'est passé parce qu'elle était
très jeune mais elle a quand même
quelques souvenirs et aussi du
témoignage de sa mère vous allez voir
qu'à un gain dans cette histoire et qui
elle a été traumatisée autant qu'ils
aient mis par cette affaire et c'est
normal à l'époque émis vit avec ses
parents sans blague au deuxième étage
d'un appartement dans une grande ville
en bord de mer faut savoir que dans les
grandes villes les places en crèches
sont rares et le sont de plus en plus
d'ailleurs du coup quand un enfant n'a
pas de place en crèche basse et par an
soit s'en occupe soit prennent une
nounou ça fait donc trois semaines que
helena s'occupe des mis toute la journée
parce que ses parents travaille
énormément et qu'elle n'a
malheureusement pas eu de places à la
crèche elena s'occupe très bien d'amy
elle est très sympa très douce et
globalement amy lui fais totalement
confiance mais il ya un mais de taille
depuis quelques jours les parents d'amy
ont remarqué des bleus sur son corps au
début ça les a pas alarmer plus que ça
en réalité on peut avoir des bleus sans
pour autant s'être pris un coup
d'ailleurs selon les personnes savary en
a vraiment qui ont beaucoup de bleu
comme ça naturellement surtout sur les
jambes c'est des trucs de circulation
sanguine bref sauf que là dans le cas
d'amy les bleus au fil du temps sont de
plus en plus nombreux et de plus en plus
foncée et décide donc de parler des
bleus à elena qui globalement n'apprécie
pas du tout elle s'énerve elles haussent
le ton et leur dit écoutez j'ai rien à
voir avec les bleus vous m'accusez à
tort vous n'avez pas honte sauf qu'elle
est nam ont tellement dans les tours que
les parents d'amy ce 10 mai à temps il
lui arrive quoi là elle est tout gentil
et douce habituellement pourquoi elle
pète un câble en revanche l'altercation
a eu lieu en début de journée et du coup
les parents d'amy n'ont pas tout de
suite dégager l ena parce qu'ils avaient
besoin d'elle pour une toute dernière
journée avant de trouver une solution
pour faire garder et mis les jours
d'après ce jour là ses parents sont donc
allés travailler comme les autres jours
en se disant bon bah voilà elena va
faire une dernière journée et ce soir on
l'a dégage la journée en question se
passe très bien mais vient le soir elana
est en train de préparer à manger mais
amy explique que c'est pas comme
d'habitude elle a pas l'air dans son
état habituel et à plusieurs reprises
elles l'appellent ana au lieu de emi
bref elena a fini de préparer à manger
donc elle l'invite émis à se mettre à
table et me s'installe elle est prête à
dévorer son repas et du coin de l'oeil
elle aperçoit l ena m 3 gélules dans son
verre d'eau et puis elle lui tende vers
et elle demande à amy de boire
évidemment et m'y refuse du coup elena
s'énerve lui crie dessus du deet est
qu'une sale gosse je t'ai demandé de
boire cette eau donc tu vas boire cette
eau et me fond en larmes elena continue
de crier dessus et exige qu'elles
boivent cette eau et puis quelqu'un se
met à cogner à la porte d'entrée et ce
quelqu'un c'est le père d'amy qui vient
d'entrer du travail mais qui en mettant
sa clé dans la serrure n'a pas réussi à
ouvrir sa propre porte d'entrée pourquoi
parce qu'il ya déjà une clés sur la
serrure mais de l'intérieur en revanche
à travers la porte le papa d'amy en
temps sa fille en larmes et entend les
cris d'elena il se met donc à crier il
ordonne à elena d'ouvrir la porte
d'entrée immédiatement elena arrête de
crier sur amy elle se dirige vers la
fenêtre du salon et elle saute elle
saute donc du deuxième étage ce qui est
possible sans se blesser si on fait une
bonne réception et quelques minutes plus
tard le père d'amy réussi à forcer la
porte et rentrer rassurer sa fille et la
prendre dans ses bras lui et sa femme
appelle immédiatement la police qui
arrive sur les lieux dix minutes plus
tard et qui pose des questions a émis
émis qui est incapable de répondre parce
qu'elle est traumatisée par ce qui vient
de se passer c'est horrible et commence
donc à fouiller l'appartement par
sécurité et ils tombent sur quelque
chose de vraiment pas rassurant dans un
tiroir de la cuisine il tombe sur un
rouleau de scotch de déménagement une
corde et un couteau qui n'était plus à
sa place dans le bloc de couteaux de la
cuisine quelques jours plus tard la
famille d'amy à des news des policiers
puisqu'ils ont arrêté lna et qu'ils ont
résolu la faire en fait ils ont appelé
la chef de l'entreprise ou elena
travailler et sept chefs leur a dit
écoutez les gars l'emploi dont vous me
parlez a été licencié il ya maintenant
un an après qu'on ait reçu plusieurs
plaintes de parents pour coup sur enfant
le jour où elle s'est volatilisée les
gélules qu'elle avait mise dans le vert
de emi c'était des somnifères c'était du
zolpidem et c'est clairement pas le
genre de médicaments que tu donnes à un
enfant de 4 ans et demi elle a pas trop
de souvenirs c'est juste un mauvais
moment mais il lui est rien arrivé de
physique ou quoi que ce soit mais voilà
il explique que ses parents même dix ans
après il s'envole encore amy je suis
ravi qu'il ne se soit rien arrivé c'est
marrant ça me fait penser enfin marrant
le mot est très mal choisi mais ça me
fait penser à quand j'étais jeune et que
j'étais j'allais à l'école primaire je
crois que j'étais en cp bon c'est vrai
j'ai failli me faire kidnapper j'ai déjà
raconté dans une vidéo anecdotes mais
c'est vrai j'ai failli me faire [ __ ]
de kidnapper c'est abusé d'ailleurs
sachez que si vous êtes victime ou que
vous avez connaissance d'une situation
de maltraitance d'un enfant il ya un
numéro qui existe c'est le 119 il est
fonctionnel 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 il est gratuit c'est un numéro
national dédié donc à la protection des
enfants en danger ou en risque de l'être
donc voilà si vous avez un doute
n'hésitez pas on sait jamais ça peut
toujours sauver des vies c'est la fin de
ce serait d'horreur j'espère que il vous
a plu c'est des trucs qu avant même de
lire des histoires comme ça c'est ma
hantise je serai angoissé non-stop
j'avais un enfant à grand respect à tous
les parents regardent les vidéos chez
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux que
vous ayez 30 ans ou 50 comment avez vous
fait maman respect on dirait bien que
dans deux ou trois jours c'est le nouvel
an amusez vous bien fêter ça comme il se
doit et on se retrouve en 2022 à l'année
prochaine
je la dis premier degré cette phrase
hockey
[Musique]